welcome back i'm just trying to show you
as many examples if possible of solving
differential equations exact
differential equations one trying to
figure out whether the equations are
exact and then if you know they're exact
how do you
figure out the psi and figure out the
solution of the differential equation so
the next one in my book is
x squared
minus 2 x y
plus 2
times
dx
plus
six
y squared minus x squared plus three
times
d y
is equal to zero
so just the way it was written this
isn't superficially in that form that we
want right what's the form that we want
we want some function of x and y
plus another function of x and y
times
y prime or d y d x
is equal to 0. we're close how could we
get this equation into this form we just
divide both sides of this equation by dx
right and then we get
x squared minus 2xy
plus 2 we're dividing by dx so that dx
just becomes a 1
plus
6 y squared minus x squared plus 3
and then we're dividing by dx so that
becomes dy dx
is equal to what's zero divided by dx
well it's just zero and there we have it
we have written this in the form that we
need in this form and now we need to
prove to ourselves that this is an exact
equation so let's do that
so what's the partial
of
m this is the m function right this is
the m function
what's the this was a plus here
what's the partial of this with respect
to y
this would be zero this would be
minus two x and then just a two so
that's the partial of this with respect
to y is minus two x what's the partial
of n with respect to x
this would be zero this would be minus
two x
so there you have it
the partial of m with respect to y is
equal to the partial of n
with respect to x and y is equal to an x
so we are dealing with an exact equation
so now we have to find psi
the partial of psi with respect to x is
equal to m which is equal to 3
x squared minus two x y plus two
take the antiderivative with respect to
x on both sides and you get psi is equal
to
x to the third
minus this is x squared y because y is
just a constant
plus 2x
plus some function of y
right because we know zi is a function
of x and y so when you take a derivative
with when you take a partial with
respect to just x
a pure function of just y would get lost
so it's like the constant when we took
when we first learned taking
anti-derivatives and now to figure out
psi we just have to solve for h of y and
how do we do that
well let's take the partial of psi with
respect to y
and that's going to be equal to this
right here so the partial of psi with
respect to y this is 0 this is minus x
squared so it's minus x squared this is
plus
h prime
of y
is going to be equal to what that's
going to be equal to our n of x y it's
going to be equal to this
and then we can solve for this so that's
going to be equal to 6 y squared minus x
squared plus 3.
can add x squared to both sides to get
rid of this
and this
and then we're left with
h prime
of y is equal to
six y squared plus three
antiderivative so h
of y is equal to
what is this 2 y
cubed plus 3y and you could put a plus c
there but
the plus c merges later on when we solve
the differential equation so you don't
have to worry about it too much
so what is our function's i i'll write
it in a new color
our function psi
as a function of x
and y
is equal to
x to the third
minus x squared
y
plus
x plus h of y which we just solved for
so h of y is plus 2 y to the third
plus 3y and then there could be a plus c
there but you'll see that it it doesn't
matter much
and actually i want to do something a
little bit different i'm not just going
to chug through the problem i want to
kind of go back to the intuition because
i don't want this to be completely
mechanical let me just show you what the
derivative
using what we know knew before you even
learned anything about
before you learned anything about um
partial the partial derivative chain
rule what is the derivative of psi with
respect to x
what is the derivative of psi with
respect to x here we just use our
implicit differentiation skills
so the derivative of this i'll do it in
a new color
is 3
x squared
minus now we're going to have to use the
chain rule here so the derivative of the
first expression with respect to x is
is well let me just put the minus sign
and i can put like that so it's
2x
times y
times the first plus the first function
x squared
times the derivative of the second
function with respect to x well that's
just
y prime right it's
the derivative of y with respect to y is
1 times the derivative of y with respect
to x which is just y prime
fair enough
plus the derivative of this with respect
to x is easy 2
to x well let's take the derivative of
this with respect to y first we're just
doing implicit differentiation in the
chain rule so this is
this is
plus
y squared
and then we're doing the chain rule so
we took the derivative with respect to y
and then you have to multiply that times
the derivative of y with respect to x
which is just y prime
plus
derivative of this with respect to y is
three
times just doing the chain rule the
derivative of y with respect to x so
that's y prime
and let's try to see if let's see if we
can simplify this so we get
this is equal to
x
squared
minus two x y
plus two so that's this term this term
and this term
plus
let's say let's take all the y let's
just put the y prime outside
y prime
times
so you have a negative sign out here
minus
x squared
plus
6 y squared
plus three
so this is the derivative of this of rsi
as we solved it and notice look at this
closely and notice that that is the same
hopefully it's the same as our original
problem what was our original problem
that we started working with the
original problem was
three x squared
minus two x y
plus two
plus
six y squared
minus x squared
plus three times y prime is equal to
zero so this was our original problem
and notice that the derivative of psi
with respect to x just using implicit
differentiation is exactly this
so hopefully this gives you a little
intuition of why we can just rewrite
this equation as the derivative
with respect to of with respect to x of
psi which is a function of x and y
is equal to zero because this is the
derivative of z with respect to x i
wrote it out here it's the same thing
it's right here
right so that equals zero
so if we take the anti-derivative of
both sides we know that the solution of
this differential equation is that
psi of x and y
is equal to c is a solution
and we know what psi is so we just set
that equal to c and we have the implicit
we have a solution to the differential
equation all this defined implicitly
so the solution you don't have to do
this every time this
step right here
this step right here you wouldn't have
to do if you were taking a test unless
the teacher explicitly asked for it i
just wanted to kind of make sure that
you know what you're doing that you're
not just doing things completely
mechanically that you really see that
the derivative of psi really does give
you like we solved for psi and i just
want to show that the derivative of psi
with respect to x just using implicit
differentiation and our standard chain
rule actually gives you the left-hand
side of the differential equation which
was our original problem
and then that's how we know that the
derivative of psi with respect to x is
equal to zero because our original
differential equation was equal to zero
you take the anti-derivative of both
sides of this you get the derivative you
get psi is equal to c is the solution of
the differential equation
or if you wanted to write it out psi is
this thing
our solution to the differential
equation is x to the third minus x
squared y
plus 2x plus 2y to the third plus 3y is
equal to c
is
the an implicitly defined
solution
of our original differential equation
anyway i've run out of time again i will
see you in the next video